best-selling author and researcher brene
brown her ted talk the power of
vulnerability has been viewed nearly
this number 60 million times her latest
research delves into 87 emotions and
experiences that she says we all have in
common she writes about all of them in
her new book it's called atlas of the
heart mapping meaningful connection and
the language of human experience renee
brown is with us in the studio and
listen before we get started renee brown
walked into the studio rapping
[Laughter]
i mean sugar hell records like you're
either just give just give the one line
that you gave to us just to brag i don't
mean to boast but i like hot better on
the breakfast toast check it out okay
bubba okay you'll see renee in the house
i had the 12 inches i know that was
pretty good that was very good renee she
had a couple of them all right so you
talked to 7 000 different people in your
research and the most common emotions
that kept coming up happy sad angry kept
coming up over and over again what does
that say about us that those were the
top three that came when there were so
many different emotions we all
experienced i was so surprised i mean we
started the research asking how many
emotions can we recognize in ourselves
as we're feeling them and i you know i
guess that the mean or the average
number would be six or seven yeah and it
was just happy sad mad yeah and it was
so alarming because when we don't have
language that's as expansive as our
actual experiences we force experiences
into language
and that's troublesome because language
does much more
than communicate what we're feeling yeah
it actually shapes what we're feeling
what got me is that i didn't even think
of things as emotions that are emotions
like you said disappointment
disappointment is unmet expectations and
disappointment and regret are interwoven
yeah i mean this is like the story of
most not only my marriage but most
people's like you have all these huge
expectations right you're like i'm gonna
walk in and this is how it's going to go
and he's going to say this and then you
know and then within seconds it doesn't
the movie doesn't play out how you had
it in your head and then what you
experience is disappointment so many
people and in particular men don't want
to name their emotions and one of the
things you hear is that if you name it
it has power over you yeah you think no
that the opposite in fact wow you have a
lot of data that support that's really a
dangerous myth when we name what we're
feeling it doesn't have power over us we
gain power
we have the ability to say i mean
there's there's really strong evidence
that shows the ability to accurately
name and recognize emotion we call it
emotional granularity
really leads to the ability to
management manage it and move through it
yeah if i identify it i have a better
chance of managing it um kind of explain
the concept of near enemies i think it's
absolutely powerful god it blew me away
so it's a buddhist concept and like
let's take an emotion like compassion we
know the far enemy of compassion is
cruelty right but the problem is that
there's a near enemy that kind of
dresses up a little bit like compassion
and we think maybe can pass for
compassion but it actually unravels
connection so the near enemy
of compassion is pity so you share i see
you struggling and i'm like oh
right you poor thing
i'm so sorry
and you're thinking god that doesn't
feel good at all
that does more damage yeah so the near
enemy concept has been super helpful the
difference between you say stress and
overwhelm which are a lot of people are
feeling these days
yeah so stress
is something that we can manage pretty
much on it we we do it every day like i
always use an analogy i used to wait
tables and bartend and we'd say i'm in
the weeds like i'm in the weeds lots of
stuff going on i'm in the weeds
overwhelm is a very high level of stress
that actually leads to shut down we
don't function when we're overwhelmed
and because language shapes what we're
experiencing if we go through the day
all day saying i'm overwhelmed i'm
overwhelmed our body says oh okay we're
kind of shutting down right yeah so it's
it's like if i said bake cookies yup
let's make some chocolate chip cookies
and the bowl we picked changed the
flavor of the cookie
the language we use
changes what we experience yeah
that's why you should be in tune with
your tune most people have three
emotions that they can name read this
book and get to 87.
renee brown thank you very much that
book is the is atlas of the heart
reading i love